[Music]
and then Jax like in the corner like
most jak2 in look into my eyes and it's
easy to see hello everyone welcome back
to a brand new edition of Collider
ladies night and I am here with one of
the stars whom onto the next level it's
Karen Gillan it's I failed already
it's not Karen Gillan it's Guerin Killen
yes I'm a tease like that's it this is
Nate he's light and the feelings bright
I'll take it
it works my joints feel like first off I
have to tell you that no junket will
ever be the same after the Jumanji the
next level junkie like you guys have
ruined junka ting for me cuz it's never
gonna be that good I think it's been
ruined for all of us so in any other
movie I'm going to be like why aren't
you playing any games with me where's
the tequila and why are we know in
Mexico what were you guys doing what we
were busy like bungee jumping in
ziplining yeah you guys were just bungee
to hang with us I absolutely know would
you would you never know know when when
I heard that you had done it I was like
you're amazing because I would not even
oh I can't think of anything worse
are you the fear of heights or anything
with no audience I don't like a drop ok
that's reasonable like when I was a
child before I would get on
rollercoasters
I would go up to the operator and be
like excuse me and how many drops are in
this rollercoaster and he's like go away
child do you go to any lego movement
parks or any other kinds of rides now um
I do when my friends are and I do like
okay I am quite scared to go in the
guardians of the galaxy one which was
formerly Tower of Terror did you go on
it when they had the big opening I did
it is dropping
it's literally only dropping it's it's
not a real drop along the lines of a
bungee jump drop it like but it's not
like a little but then you kind of like
slowly come up a little and then go back
it's worse because it's drops with
anticipation in the middle it's not that
bad oh not that bad at all one day I'll
do it and I'll film it okay I want to
see that when it happens so on Collider
sometimes we play a filmmaking version
of would you rather I think we played at
the junket but I do have another junket
related question who are you would you
rather do a junket with a co-star who
talks too much or not enough because
I've been on the receiving end of both
of those things you Aquafina and Jack
black just had pitch perfect chemistry
for something like that I know we
actually had so much fun I would say I'm
gonna go with someone who talks too much
because I don't want to have to talk too
much I'm I I sort of just get to the
point quite quickly and but then I you
know I've been with actors and I'm not
naming names who I I think that they
finished talking but then they start up
again so I'm always like and I would
like to sorry okay and I keep on and I
just I can't get the rhythm I feel like
even just sitting on the opposite side I
have the same thing everyone so I never
know I'm gonna someone's like very
breathy but then they keep taught to say
you just don't know yeah and also I feel
for you guys on the other side when one
person takes a really long time to
answer a question and then your time is
up and you haven't asked anyone else a
question as long as it's an answer of
substance though I will take it yeah as
long as the person ran with the question
I have another junket related question
for you ever since joining the first
guardians of the galaxy movie are you
ever not asked about Marvel in an
interview setting no one pretty sure it
comes up in every single interview so to
continue that trend and not ruin it when
your guardians the galaxy's very nice
that was one my one little dig it's not
gonna happen again
I want to go back to the very beginning
of your career cause one of the things I
like to ask about most is what was the
film the performance anything at all
that made you say I got to get into the
industry and do that oh that's a good
big question I think the first film I
can ever remember seeing was a little
shop of horrors which I thought was
called the planets because my dad had
like recorded off the TV and cold at the
when a sticker that he put on the
videotape and so I was like the plan
scary and Audrey's cool and so I think
that that really got me interested in
films and musicals and things and then
you know a lot of friends a lot of
friends up at the top of Scotland it was
like the dream life because they had
loads of friends and they lived in New
York and they all just had great lives
and I was like I'm gonna get that for
myself oh I'm so curious now coming from
that did you envision going to New York
or to LA to hit it fake cuz I'm a little
partial to New York even though I love
LA right now I might be a little partial
to New York as well smart and I think
well it's halfway home for me and it
does you can definitely feel that - um
LA is no bad place to live at all it's a
good quality of life but like I think I
imagine living in New York but in terms
of making it yeah you would imagine that
happens in Los Angeles when you thought
about making it and you pictured
yourself in Hollywood or wherever how
does that compare to kind of the career
that you've led thus far did you picture
yourself like I'm gonna be an action
star I'm gonna be in comedy or anything
like that neither of those things I grew
up in Scotland studying Greek tragedies
and also other stuff too but like a Luda
stage stuff really and I did have
ambitions to get onto screen though not
just stage but like action stuff no I
didn't think it was plausible for
someone like me weigh my spaghetti
running around the Moors of Scotland I
like I just don't
I never thought that would happen and
and then when it started happening I was
like I'm a full fraud and you're gonna
find out that I am terrible at this at
some point and now I'm not terrible at
it anymore
I'm actually quite good at it how many
of your own stunts do you do in this new
Jumanji movie compared to the first one
do you do a bit more this time I am it's
definitely do more of my own stunts this
time around well we had the team from
Mission Impossible come on - with your
magic oh my god your second unit
director um yes yes that's very excited
oh I'm Tom Cruise level now
hi Spencer and Bethany this next
adventure is even more challenging this
time not all of you will leave the game
alive
nobody Tom Cruise that's when you become
official food trees yeah you got a run
him in a race I mean Tom Cruise running
is like next-level running I feel like I
can rival that run yeah yeah I've really
thought about every every finger
placement everything you say it like a
joke I feel like finger placement is
important I'm saying it like a joke but
it was no joke yours I feel like you're
supposed to run with your with your
fingers out I think like to cut the air
yeah I mean it is like heretics Nebula
runs with the straight hands out but if
you're a human I'll just give it a
gentle okay
gentle curve edge nebula is basically
like a machine so she has to do
everything like for peak efficiency
exactly if you take any of nebula with
you like do you have any like robotic
qualities now that kind of mimic what
you do when you play her I think maybe I
might tilt my head sometimes
which is something I developed on the
first guardians of the galaxy where she
kind of just does a little which just
looks a lot better in the makeup then it
does right now with my face because I
just look like a little dog I will never
forget seeing you in the makeup for the
first time in person on the set of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and just
doing like a normal interview like full
yes tuberculous nebula and we were like
behind dave in line on the the lunch
line and he's just dressed as Rex just
like getting food yeah just shirtless
and covered in things probably business
as usual for you yeah it becomes very
normal you know per day he has to get
into a sauna at the end of the day oh
yeah like seven guys and they all just
get their shorts on get sweat in and
take that makeup off do what you got to
do so this is a little convoluted but
I'm gonna try to get this across kind of
clearly so when you're first starting
out in the industry I imagine it's
almost like a feeling where you don't
want to say no to anything so you can
gain more experience especially when
opportunities come your way new line you
want to start off your career building
your resume in a way that kind of speaks
to you with projects that are important
to you so at the very beginning did you
have a tough time or how did you figure
out how to find that balance between the
two mentalities it's true you know it's
you know you you need to get your fit in
the door but you don't want to go down
an avenue that you didn't you know
picture yourself
going you know so I think I definitely
dabbled in some things I didn't see in
the long run I mean I auditioned for to
be like an actor in the chamber of
horrors in London which is like an
experience where you jump out at people
and you're one of the actors and I
didn't get it well I wake what kind of
creature were you well I like that they
said that my character was really weird
and not working so I don't know what I
was doing like basically everyone got a
part in this I must have been really off
to not get this so I feel like what you
should do in order to kind of like
fulfill this missed opportunity is one
day you should go to the Halloween
Horror Nights folks and you should ask
them to let dress you up one night and
just give me that opportunity it looks
like so much fun I mean I would love
that
I actually went to that haunted hayride
thing haunted hayride is great I was
looking at all the actors and I was like
you know what these characters are
better than what I did and that room
that day so you're no big drops but you
will take the thrill of like a haunted
house yes experience yeah and I really
really like buy into it as well like
there's a lot of screaming happening
okay oh yeah as long as it's one or the
other I'm cool with that yeah just going
back to the beginning again just with
the idea of auditioning too because I
think it's beneficial for just about
anyone out there no matter what field
they're in to hear about you know
someone's experiences of failure and how
they overcome it so you don't get an
audition what's the quickest way you
could find to kind of snap out of it
kind of give yourself that boost to
carry on and go for another project I
think you just it's all in your mental
states you know if somebody said to you
you're gonna get everything that you're
aiming for in five years right you would
just kind of relax a little bit and be
like okay it doesn't matter about that
audition so you kind of have to adopt
that mindset because that is true belief
in yourself and I think that luckily I
was born with that but I do think that
you can acquire that through sort of
just really being mindful of it and
being positive and just sort of really
believing in yourself because you have
to before everybody else is going to
what was the very first time you were
flat-out offered a role where you didn't
have to audition for it
who
it must have been so I started on a TV
show in the UK called Doctor Who never
know that well random time-travel show
and I think after that I maybe got some
offers but nothing huge maybe like
independent films Doctor Who kind of the
like the breakout role for you in terms
of because you know it's one thing to
sit there and say look I want to be an
actor and work really hard for it it's
another to really believe that it's
gonna be a real career for you was that
the role that kind of shifted that
mentality at all and again going back to
the mentality I already had that
mentality which is that's why I keep
reinforcing this if you have that then
you're you're likely to do it it's a
mind it's a state of mind and so I
already had that but that definitely
reinforced it for me
who encouraged you to have that kind of
state of mind like as a kid growing up
where do you get that from what's the
source ink my dad I think that's where
it came from but neither of my parents
ever expressed doubt when I said I want
to be an actress and I want to do this
they weren't like oh it's a tough career
they were like go for it
and so for me I was like this is
plausible and achievable they think it
is I think it is and then my dad would
talk to me about how much Drive it would
really take to for someone like you know
or I don't know the Beatles for example
they had you know John Lennon was
incredibly driven random example you
know so he's never a bad example no I
know and I hope you don't think I'm
comparing myself to the fields because
that that's a catastrophe but no I you
know he talked to me about how much
Drive it was required in order to get
that far with your career and so I kind
of learned about Drive and I was like oh
I wonder if I have that I remember
asking that like do I have Drive and
then somehow I think that just making me
aware of it kind of gave me a lot of it
this might be making you repeat the same
answer but coming from that kind of
background and just with the mentality
you seem to have for someone out there
who maybe is just starting as an actor
what advice would you give them I mean
mine stay is everything I mean you know
you can walk into a room and have the
attitude of I'm gonna get this and this
is my time and how can you help me do
what I need to do or you can walk in the
room and be like how can I please you
oh god I probably won't get this you
know and there's a huge difference there
and also I would say you have to have
that mind state you have to be
incredibly proactive and work really
hard and create opportunities for
yourself and be self generating I can't
emphasize that enough because people
aren't just gonna be like here have all
the jobs you have to really go after it
and eventually it will start coming back
and paying dividends I like all that
advice whether it's for acting or really
for anything yeah you're in - how did
Jumanji come about for you the original
one is that something you audition for
did they kind of fit you into the the
other three and I think that you were
the right fit for that you know no it
was just a normal audition I look at
they didn't have me in mind or anything
like that I remember getting the
audition on the day I rapped on
guardians of the galaxy volume 2 and I
was like ah done it and had a glass of
wine and then ping audition for Jumanji
and I'm like I love the original so I
was like oh this is sort of thing what
were you picturing when you got that
pain as a fan of the original because I
am a die-hard fan of that 1995 movie or
when I first heard about this I'm like
uh-oh I don't know how you're gonna do
this especially when I first heard about
the video game idea I'm like I think
this is going to work you're taking away
the texture of the one I want
yeah isn't true in the end
run they just stampede
well no I I kind of had a similar
reaction I was like what are you gonna
do with my Jumanji I love this film and
why are you remaking this of all things
like the reaction that I think everybody
had and then I read the script and I was
like oh this is gonna be really good and
this group of people working on it are
so talented it's in safe hands and then
I was like oh I have to get this this
makes all the sense in the world for me
and so please let it happen do you
remember what you had to do in the
audition yeah I had to go in and read
like three scenes with Jake the director
and the casting directors and I remember
distinctly everyone was dressed in the
outfit or like variations of the outfit
and I didn't because I was like it's
kind of very Martha to not want to wear
that and so I remember thinking that's
like a different choice where I'm not
dressed as Lara Croft you what was it
like the first time all four of you were
in costume and you were kind of standing
there together because that image of all
four of you is it's like it's a powerful
shot but remember that Raymond actually
because we were doing a screen test and
the director just stood back and he was
like whoa you all look amazing together
and I've been picturing this for months
and you could just feel the electricity
like we were making something really
cool already you feel it there's
something about seeing all four of you
together in those outfits and knowing
that your avatars that kind of encourage
is almost like like maybe I would
describe it as like a wish fulfillment
thing like you want to play along and
which one would be yours yeah that's a
filming yeah backtracking just a little
bit when you would I guess got the roll
and you first found out you're really
starring opposite Kevin Hart Dwayne
Johnson Jack Black you work with so many
wonderful people
stars that were very familiar with but
was there an intimidation factor or was
there any one of the bunch you were
almost nervous to work with Oh God
complete intimidation yeah there's three
giant movie stars and I've worked with
giant movie stars before but never in a
sort of equal parts capacity you know so
this was my first time having to step up
to that position and I was definitely
the newbie and not everyone knows who I
am you know so it was like really
intimidating but they were so supportive
and they really kind of made it a lot
easier for me
could have been but also everyone else
had just been offered their roles
obviously I auditioned so many times and
did a big screen test in Hawaii I'd done
everything so there was also a comfort
to knowing that I had earned that role I
had really worked hard and they knew I
was going to do with it so there was it
that was kind of nice I still kind of
can't believe you had a law dition for
the role for whatever it from the
outsider's perspective it's like you see
guardians and you're like oh this makes
all the sense in the world it was meant
to be so all right so someone behind the
camera there's gonna get mad at me but I
want to play a little game with the
three of them so we were trying to think
of you know three different things and
obviously [ __ ] marry kill came down came
up so here you had a sort Kevin
Dwayne oh good job you could do it
really really quickly
I have a backup version that's a little
more PJ yeah what's the backup the
backup version is like a movie a movie
version to have a fight scene with a cry
scene with or an improv scene with a
fight scene with a cry scene with an
improv see guys okay from the cast of
Jumanji yes okay improv scene with Kevin
Hart
because he improvises all the time he's
it's not up comedian of course he does
and cry scene and what was the other one
fights I seen I'm fighting the rock I
had a feeling you're doing that Johnson
against me he's gonna lose and then I'm
gonna cry with Jack Black okay yeah I
would probably have predicted that yes
this is a very nice inappropriate
question we were talking about it
yesterday and the person I was going
over it with it's like you don't have
the nerve but now I have proof I tried
the question I can't no I see I feel
uncomfortable I've been answering that
so another thing I'm dying to ask you
about is your interest in working behind
the scenes as well because there's
nothing that excites me more than
somebody working in the film industry
who has experience and know-how in so
many different departments so at what
point did you realize you know you want
to make your own movies too
well when I was a kid and my parents
gave me a video camera and I
make horror films all around to my house
in Scotland so I have like a million
follow-up questions like overload with
question everyone out there knows like
Horrors my John right I freaked out with
I made your favorite really one of the
first things I vividly remember you in
is oculus and I'll never forget my first
South by Southwest Film Festival this
one I saw oculus and the first time I
met Mike Flanagan that movie just very
soon you must be hungry
the favorite of all time though is
scream scream I love scream - that's
really up there for me it makes me so
meta its aware of itself it's funny
exactly how everything how do you feel
about the possibility of getting another
screen movie would you rather see them
do a scream five more completely reboot
the franchise I do like a bit of Neve
Campbell if they're gonna reboot that
franchise I'm gonna need Neve in the mix
yeah she might not need to be Sidney
Prescott but she needs to be in the
movie otherwise it's no scream Neve
Campbell David Arquette and Courtney I
feel like I'm just describing scream 4
all over again I would like to see that
going back to your horror films like
what kind of horror movie were you
making as a kid was it what paranormal
was it / it was slasher because I grew
up watching scream and I know what you
did last summer and those like process
of elimination teen horror films and so
I played I would be in it and direct and
write it and I was this killer with long
blonde hair you were the killer I was
the killer
yeah also and I take an eye sight and
and I was like this nice girl during the
day and at night I would go out with my
blonde wig on and murder people with my
knife and then I murdered my dad in the
horror film which is crazy in hindsight
but he had a really good time and he was
my favorite actor too cussed and he can
do a convincing death scene and so I was
like this is your moment dad do you
still have any of these anywhere is
there like archival footage somewhere I
don't know where but I think I can find
it when I go home to Scotland I'm going
to do so you have that interest when
you're younger and then you know correct
me if I'm wrong here but then you get
into acting and you start to make a
career for yourself there at what point
in your acting career do you realize you
kind of want to make that pivot and is
there any concern that oh if I start
pursuing directing then what if I leave
acting behind and lose opportunities I
think it probably came about when I was
24 and I was just finishing on Doctor
Who and I started writing this script
which became the film the party's just
beginning which was my directorial debut
and
and I just decided I wanted to direct it
I don't remember the actual moment when
that happened but then I started making
short films and completely fell in love
with it and I was like oh this feels
like a whole part of myself that I
haven't really explored but it's
something that you like really need to
do even having worked on some big
projects what was the one thing about
directing your own movie whether it was
a short or your first feature then
really surprised you I think I don't
know if there was any surprises it
surprised me how natural it felt like I
thought I was gonna be more overwhelmed
or freaked out but I was like calm and
and felt at home and was like ah this
feels like exactly right
not to say that there wasn't challenged
as if there were daily challenges but
like it just didn't feel too stressful
or anything like that and also I just
loved the freedom that it gave me like
to express myself in this whole way that
I haven't before
whatever the first short you made was
did you act in that as well
no I didn't know I cast my friend rose
McIver of iZombie Fame every good friend
to cast I know she was amazing in it and
then I made that short and then I made
another short that I was in as well as
directing and that was really fun but I
think next time I need to not be in it
oh really is that from your experience
directing the feature yeah just because
I love to be behind the monitor I don't
know to really look at the composition
of the shots and really see what's
happening and I had a very much I you
know I was in control of what the film
looked like but just to not be able to
obsess over the visuals as much as I
wanted to was it annoying are you the
kind of director that wants to do as
many takes as possible or you know you
know I know when I get it and I'm ready
to move on and well I know that I have
restrictions that I need to stay within
timewise and budget wise but if I can
push it I'm gonna keep going to get it
right but when we've got it right I feel
very confident then I'm like okay we can
move on but I don't stop until we get it
okay they're probably a smart move you
want to be confident in the shot at the
end no yeah because you know they tried
to move you on a lot you know so you
really have to fight to just keep going
sometimes can you tell me about the
choice
to run with the party's just beginning
for your first feature because I'll be
completely honest I didn't do any
reading on it other than the fact that
you directed it and for whatever reason
I jumped into it assuming I don't know
why I thought this but that it would be
like a party comedy and it's it's not
that at all it's it's very very heavy
material and at least from my
perspective it seems like that would be
a very intimidating first feature
well you Ramesh I wasn't always like
this coming up to here
yeah in hindsight I agree with you at
the time I was just like it just flowed
out with me it was 20 for him and I
wrote that it was based on the suicide
rates and the highlands of Scotland
where I'm from they're really high and I
always knew I wanted to write something
about that because it's beautiful up
there it's a really nice existence and
I'm like why is this happening and so
this film is me exploring that really so
when you come up with an idea like that
and you write the script who's the first
person you go to to tell that person
like I'm ready to make this let's do it
um you know the first person I think I
maybe showed it to is Mike Flanagan that
seems like the right person yeah because
I was filming oculus at the time and
then he read it and he was like you
should make this and I know who you
should make it with and here's a
producer she's coming in right now and
he set me up with my producer Molly
Elfman and oh my god fons that's her
exactly
oh you directed a piece of one of them
right okay I was practicing for the
future huh yeah I love the sound of that
yeah and you're making another short now
right so I just made another one before
we show up Jumanji earlier this year and
to scratch that edge before I
disappeared into two films so I made
that and it's taken me nine months and
I'm not finished you your thoughts were
there ready to be fit I feel like that's
the most empty comment to say because
I've felt that you know the finish line
keeps extending me getting further and
further because you could keep tweaking
and well that's what I'm doing also I've
been busy on the film so it's not as if
I've just been obsessing over this one
thing however I'm so glad I'm taking all
this time because we've really cool
interesting choices three how do you
think you're directing experience has
changed how you work on set as an actor
I think I just understand what the
directors are after a bit more I
understand their motivations for why
they might be asking me to do something
and therefore I can make it really a lot
quicker for them because I'll be like oh
that's that you need this right because
of that and they're like yeah great and
the flipside is there any specific
element of filmmaking that you're dying
to learn more about I think editing that
would be the top choice for me because I
because I'm really hands on in the Edit
like one frame or oh no I was wrong back
one no it was
- forward it's just like painstaking it
would be so much easier to just be like
done understandable there with all of
the incredible directors Mike Flanagan
and Jake Kasdan included that you've
worked with who do you think as a
director you've benefited from observing
the most while you're on set of their
movie I don't know if I could choose one
you could choose well they're all
amazing I've been so lucky with the
directors I've worked with I mean top
top of the industry it's you are most
ordinary people with such unique styles
and I mean I feel like that can only
help in every single respect yeah it's
true and everyone has their own little
way of doing things that's so
interesting and helpful like Mike
Flanagan was an editor first yeah he
really shoots today the way he's gonna
edit it which is a time-saver and then
you know James Gunn is one of the most
performance friendly directors I've ever
worked with because he's so free and he
just speaks to you over a microphone and
he's like do another one do it funnier
do it saturd it regretful okay one for
you fun run and it's just like you don't
even have time to overthink it you're
deciding I'm doing it fun run you can do
whatever you want I don't care what that
applies to I'm just gonna use that
phrase from now on well actually I took
the fun run into my film which is a
serious film but I would be like after
every take and okay this is one's for
you it's a fun run do whatever you want
you don't have to say the lines you
don't have to do anything that we've
worked on just do whatever comes
naturally to you and the film is mainly
constructed of fun runs I love the sound
of that I don't know what it's gonna do
for any of our shows but we're having
fun runs all the time now all right I
got the wrap-up sign sadly but we like
to end these episodes of ladies night
with some rapid-fire Collider random
questions okay I think I've got five for
you here well this is your onset vice I
think they were stripped away from me on
Jumanji because of that outfit but I
would say it's Eminem's such a good face
to have what's the last show you watched
a full season of unbelievable on Netflix
or get to the love island have you seen
that I'm aware of love islands because
of fund of mine does the the hosting of
that oh you're going to lose your life
I'm in big trouble what is your best
celebrity impressions
I like to just do requests I don't have
one so they make one request yeah can I
get a little bit of Dewayne a little bit
of Kevin and a little bit of Jack that
was three requests but I feel like we've
got to work them in here here I go
Dwayne I just wanted to be able to say
thank you there's a lot of mountain on
the room and then Kevin comes in the
door what the hell I'm sorry
and then Jack's like in the corner like
what's Jack doing look into my eyes and
it's easy to see
so basically Jumanji 3 is just gonna be
you playing all four roles that's right
that's what me and the studio are
talking about I'm totally open to that
all right last question for you what is
your biggest fear overcome what was my
biggest fear overcome or come a fear
that you had whether it's something
moviemaking relating related or anything
else that you have overcome recently
maybe presenting awards that really
freaks me out
okay because I'm not a TV presenter like
you I don't understand how you can do
that I should bet every single time I do
something like that I like that word yes
I can tell okay what is the last thing
you presented I think it was a People's
Choice Awards cool oh oh my god it's so
scary because like you're reading this
thing and you're like this is just I
don't know why because I don't have any
emotions to channel the energy into
you're just kind of just this thing just
exposed standing there see that's when
you have to use the mentality we're
talking about at the beginning of the
episode you have your confidence and you
present that absolutely right you got
this thank you thank you so much for
your time today Karen back
congratulations on the movie everybody
out there Jumanji the next level in
theaters nationwide on December 13th
check it out also hey why don't you
watch me bungee jumps because that was
incredible and a thing I'm never gonna
forget thanks to these guys right here
thank you so much for watching this
edition of Collider ladies night like
and share this episode before you leave
and we'll see you soon with more this is
Nate is light can the feel and right
this is Nate is life oh what a light all
alight
[Music]
copy and paste them every single episode
[Music]
[Applause]